what is bitcoin bitcoin is a
decentralized computer network it's a
currency and it's the network by
decentralized i mean there isn't one
single hub or one single area where
these computers are based they are based
everywhere and these computers also
known as miners secure the network by
running complicated computer processes
and bitcoin is the native currency of
the bitcoin network bitcoin is a form of
digital money but it's also known as
digital gold because of its store of
value characteristics there will only
ever be 21 million bitcoin but not all
exist yet so when i send you bitcoin
it's the miners all around the world
that confirm and verify that this
transaction
is correct the transactional data goes
into a block and that block is added to
the blockchain miners actually compete
against each other so that they can be
responsible for that entire block
because they're awarded with bitcoin for
all their computational work if you have
any questions let me know and i'll do a
part two